welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 24 and
we're gonna learn how you can be a
leader like a billionaire enjoy
[Music]
i think just generally the the path to
leadership should not be
through um you know basically
mba business school situation it's it's
like it should be
kind of work your way up do useful
things and um
you know and there's there's a bit too
much of the somebody goes to
a high-profile mba school and then kind
of parachutes in
as the as the leader but they don't
actually know how things work
um they you know they could be good at
say powerpoint presentations or
something like that
and they can present well but they don't
actually know how things work
because they do not um you know they
didn't
they they they didn't they like
parachute instead of like working their
way out yeah
yeah they never went through an
apprenticeship from yeah
yeah yeah they're so they're they're
kind of like just not
aware of what's really needed for uh you
know to make to make great products
um so i mean i don't want to trash
mbas too much here and i actually do
have a dual undergrad
wharton undergrad and physics um at
upenn
so um you know so i have like you know
it's
i have direct exposure to to uh
um you know to business school and i
went
you know to do undergrad business with
with physics
but um and and i was a teaching
assistant for two
semesters and i graded mbas and uh
undergrads
um so uh but i think it's just a little
bit too much
like like people look at mba school as
like i want to parachute into being the
boss instead of earning it
and like i don't think that's that's
good my opinion
is that um i can do some things that
amazon
that are would be hard for other people
to do only because of my history with
the company
and my as the company has grown of
course
my job has changed very much and um
it has my main job today is i'm kind of
the
i i i work hard at helping to maintain
the culture
um you know a culture of high standards
of operational excellence of
you know of inventiveness of willingness
to fail
willingness to make bold experiments i'm
the i'm i'm i'm you know i'm the guy i'm
the counterbalance to the institutional
know who can say yes
um but i won't you know i'm not going to
be here forever amazon is a really
the many of the traits that make amazon
unusual
are now deeply ingrained in the culture
in fact if i wanted to change them i
couldn't if i decided
tomorrow that i wish amazon did less
pioneering
and more close following i couldn't do
it
the culture is um is
you know cultures are self-reinforcing
and that's a good thing
um you know the the the people who come
to the company
we get sometimes people come to the
company and they can't they're
they find amazon very boring because we
don't have enough you know competitive
zeal
you know we don't wake up some annual
planning processes and so
and some companies literally start with
who are our three biggest enemies
and then you know here's how we're going
to hold them at bay or defeat them
and we don't have such a list at amazon
it's not how our annual planning process
works
and so but if you're on the other hand
if you're the kind of person who gets up
in the morning and says
in the shower time you know what can we
invent for customers and what can we do
differently and
how can we improve that experience and
so on so on then you know then it's
going to be a playground
is there i still run into work by the
way i took my family on vacation
to uh france my wife's extended family
there are about 20 of us
and we had an unbelievably good time
great food everything we were there for
a week i got back to seattle and i ran
into the office i'm having so much fun
i'm actually a big fan of anecdotes in
business not building a narrative
structure around them necessarily but
i still have an email address that
customers can write to
i see most of those emails and i don't
answer
very many of them anymore but but i see
them
and i and i forward them some of them
the ones that catch my curiosity i
forward them
to the executives in charge of that area
with a question mark and that question
mark is just a shorthand
for can you look into this why is this
happening what does it
what's going on and what i
find is very interesting is we have tons
of metrics we have
you know weekly business reviews with
these metric decks and we look at our we
know
so many things about customers and their
uh
their you know whether we're delivering
on time uh
what you know whether the packages have
too much air in them and you know
wasteful of packaging and so we have so
many metrics
that we monitor and the thing i have
noticed is that when the anecdotes
and the data disagree the anecdotes are
usually
right there's something wrong with the
way you're measuring it
and that's why it's so important to to
keep your
you need to run something that you were
doing you know shipping billions of
packages a year for sure you need good
data and metrics are you delivering on
time you're delivering time in every
city
are you delivering on time to apartment
complexes are you delivering on time in
certain countries
you do need the data but then you need
to check that data
with your intuition and your instincts
and you need to teach that to
the all the senior executives uh and and
junior executives too
what are the qualities of your
leadership that make you
successful at such diverse pursuits
and what works for in one area that
maybe doesn't work in another
well i tell you it works in all areas
because
i my life is fueled by my being
and the being fuels the doing so i come
from a
centered place i come from a focused
place
i come from compassion
it's just my nature i come from a
willingness to understand
and to be understood and i come from
wanting to
to to connect i mean the secret of that
show for 25 years
is that people could see themselves in
me
all over the world they could see
themselves in me
and even as i became
more and more uh financially successful
which was a big surprise to me i was
like oh my god this is so
um exciting mean you got more than that
thirty thousand i got more than thirty
thousand
by the time i was thirty so
so my but what i realized
is through the whole process because i'm
grounded
in my own self
that although i could have more shoes
my feet stayed on the ground although i
was wearing better shoes these are kind
of cute today too
so i could keep my feet on the ground
even though i could get more shoes
and i could understand i could
understand that it really was because i
was grounded i've done the
was doing and continue to this day to do
the consciousness work i work at staying
awake
and being awakened is just another word
for spirituality but spirituality throws
people off and they think you mean
religion
when i was hiring people for my company
for own
uh looking for presidents uh when people
would come in i'd say tell me what is
your spiritual practice
and literally with throat people i'm
dumb well i well i'm not religious or
i said i didn't ask you about your
religion i ask you what's your spiritual
practice
what do you do to take care of yourself
what do you do to keep yourself centered
what do you do
to the and uh you know one woman started
crying you know that's not the person
that's a sign that's a sign so so to
answer your question
everything is fueled that comes from me
really wanting to
be a better person on earth leadership
is not only about inspiring
leadership is those people who join your
company
you have to create value for him you
have to making sure
in three years he will be different
not because his job is different because
if the people not different
the products will never be different i
told
many people when they joined alibaba i
say guys
i don't know fortunate or unfortunate to
enjoy alibaba
we work much longer than the others
much harder we had more problems than
most of the companies
if you can survive in alibaba you can
survive at any company in the world
because life is tough we never promise
you will be rich you'll be successful
you will probably promote it but we will
promise
you you will be a problem
you have a wrong you will make a mistake
you have a terrible boss
we all promised so you set the
expectation
but have a good vision so that is the
way we manage
the company and i think
when you hide good people the good
people
believe the vision they will go so when
i visiting a company
whether it's a good ceo or not i do not
listen to the ceo
i listen to his people if the people
believe the vision
all the people believe this guy if the
people believe the vision
if the people believe this guy this
company has hope
a good a good entrepreneur
can always tell good stories i don't
need to listen story from you guys
i can tell your people right if your
people
any young people in your company he can
tell me the vision
he can tell me what they're doing
that is a good company
that's leadership leadership making sure
everybody when they sleep
when they drink when they talk when they
go to toilet they talk your vision
and they believe it i found out some
great leaders in the world
they are always positive they never
complain others
and never complain and
they they look at the things in a
different view like normal people
so i think people
in my company
they at the beginning they don't like me
because i'll always think about
10 years five years
and then after we're working together
for three or five years they find
you all right then we got the credit
rating and as a ceo one of the jobs
where everybody is happy you have to see
the unhappy things
when everybody's unhappy you have to see
the happy things
so leadership is nature but you have to
have a train
and learn and i got my leadership
sub upgraded in davos i see so many
uh you know alien financing how many
people here know about alipay
thank you ali pace decision was made
here
i was thinking about alipay you know but
i was not
there to launch alipay because in china
if you do financing without license you
will be in jail at that time
so i said i went to the banks can you
help us do the e-commerce
transaction no no no no no no banks
would accept it
so if there will be no alipay no
financing the e-commerce go nowhere
so i was year 2004 i was
here listen to a
speech by two state leaders
about leadership and this guy's
leadership
is about responsibility you believe it
but don't peop the people don't believe
it but if you think it's so critical
you should pay any price to do it so
that they changed my mind and i call
back to my
team say let's launch it
within one month if somebody has to go
to the jail
i go to the gym who will be the second
one follow me
if i go you continue and you go to the
jail
you're going to continue that was the
called the leadership determination
and year 2004 i made a decision here i
called it back
and now today the alipay launched and
it's so big over you know 800 million
people today using alipay
hello bullet if you look around the
world at the people that
succeed and the people that other people
want to work with the natural leaders
it isn't because they have the highest
iq or they can kick a football the
furthest or anything like that
they're people that you want to work
with i mean i've got a wonderful friend
named tom murphy i know
i would do anything for him you know
he's never going to ask me to do it but
i mean i wanted
but i want to do it i i want to do it i
mean he's done so many things for me and
then
and you know i you know you don't have
to pay me to do it or anything of the
sort that
that though that's what you want to you
want to look for that and then you want
to be that
you never wanted to beat your
competition
no i want to be successful you said
teammates versus competition right
yeah but but i mean at solomon brothers
all those times i
you work with other people one of the
ways incidentally stephanie to really
get ahead
is to give credit to somebody else when
i say oh i didn't do it lloyd did that
and he involved me
let me tell you i'm telling everybody
it's me as well
but i've now made a friend and you
respect me because i've shared the
credit
and if you say no me me me i i um
nobody likes you and nobody respects you
and they think you
are exaggerating everything but to the
extent you give credit to elsewhere
the thought of are they exaggerating
doesn't even come up
if i could get my employees one at a
time
to reach out and talk
and engage a guest on a very personal
level
not a dealer talking to a blackjack
player
but annie talking to mr jones
how are you today mr jones nice to see
you again
is there anything i can do for you you
feel like playing blackjack this morning
how's your wife all of a sudden forget
the
crystal chandeliers and the handwoven
carpets and the marble it means nothing
all of a sudden you're engaged with
someone who cares about you
if i could arrange for my employees
to find that gratifying and rewarding
and increasing of their self-esteem i
would have plugged into the magic
of business and i finally
with the help of some other people
figured it out
four five six years ago and it changed
my business
and changed my life it was a subject
that i'm going to explain to you called
storytelling
we took 900 supervisors that win
and put them in school it took about
three or four hours of training with
some people
from england and we explained to him
that
we had a structure in the company that
was very convenient
in every part of the hotel which runs as
you know 24 hours a day
we have a pre-shift meeting if it's a
restaurant just before the restaurant
opens the maitre d or the manager meets
with the
waiters and has a 10-minute session
the chef in the kitchen meets with his
cooking line and has a session
housekeepers on each floor meet with the
inspectors
that are the supervisors on each floor
of the hotel
department by department public area
porters
there are collections of 12 to 15 people
or maybe as few as seven with a line
supervisor
who gives them whatever it is they need
to learn that day before they start
their shift
we had a structure in place in the hotel
that was very convenient
but instead of giving them inane or
ordinary or mundane information
we changed the program to this
the supervisor said to the group of
eight or 10 or 12 people
has anybody got a story of
something that happened yesterday
or in the past week special with a guest
and now i'm going to give you a true
example bellman says that a bell captain
yeah yesterday i
checked in a man and his wife
older couple from california and
the bags came in and i asked them to
check and see if all the bags were
there and the woman
let out a hoot oh my god herbie
i forgot the medicine bag
and that was a small hand case in which
his medicine he was a diabetic
and her medicine they were in their 70s
were contained
oh my god herbie your insulin is in the
bag
i left it on the front hall
table when we got in the car oh my god
what are we going to do we'll have to go
back
i'll call the airport bellman tells the
bell captain
i told him just a minute ma'am where do
you live
pacific palisades is there anybody at
home at your house
well our housekeeper's there i have a
brother that lives in encino
it's a it's a latino billman my brother
herve lives in encino
why don't i give him a call he can go
over to your house
and pick up the bag and we'll manage to
get it here for you when do you need the
medicine
it was three o'clock in the afternoon
she says by 7 am
he says don't you worry if you can get
that lady on the phone
tell her that herve mendes is coming
and we'll get it here at 7 00 in the
morning
you can do that yes ma'am
she calls he waits she calls tells the
housekeeper
is the bag there yes you left it on the
front hall table
hervey is coming to get it let him have
it within the next hour
okay bye you're sure you can do it
please lady enjoy dinner have a good
time
everything's going to be fine i promise
kid goes downstairs
tells the bellman on duty the supervisor
that he's got to go get the bag jumps
into his car
drives five hours to his brother's house
picks up the bag
turns around and gets back to las vegas
at four in the morning
takes the bag to the bellman and says
make sure this gets to room tenno
whatever it was
by 7 am it's got the ladies medicine
i'm not done with the story the
relevance of this story
there's a thousand of those a month the
supervisor has been trained
everybody in the room says wow that's
great
mendes we have an internet
loop a special internet thing in the
hotel for the employees
and we have a sign shop and we make
signs for the back of the house
immediately a picture is taken of that
belmon mendez
his story is encapsulated in large print
we make paper signs and we decorate the
back of the house
we publish mendez's picture and story on
the internet
and it's all over the employees staff
dining room and everybody is reading
about this bellman
who's now a local hero and his chest is
out to here
and he's taken a bow and he feels great
because of the recognition he's getting
from his peer group
now everybody else in the room with that
bellman is looking for a story so they
can tell it the next day
we found we found a key we found a key
to making a single employee acting with
a single guest
instantly gratifying and increasing of
their self-esteem
now every employee in the hotel is
looking for a story
the the dealers are on their way down
the hall to take a break at the staff
dining room
and they see a lady and a man looking a
little confused
and they walk over on break and say you
look like you're looking for something
can i help you
and he says well we're looking for a
meeting room called lafitte
oh that's our ballroom you're
you're standing here by the bee bar you
have to go down
past wing lay the chinese restaurant
wait a minute come on with me i'll take
you
and the dealer makes a detour for five
minutes
and takes this couple and shows them the
lafitte room
you think that that hotel is ever going
to be the same
again to those two people or that lady
and her husband
with the insulin l
screw the chandeliers and the hand woven
fabrics and the onyx and the marble it
means nothing
they're going to tell their friends what
an incredible place my hotel is
we've taken storytelling 24 hours a day
seven days a week every day of the year
to a great discipline in our company
giving people recognition for doing the
one thing that creates a franchise
that's struck stronger than anything i
know about
that applies to your business you've got
to find those ideas
that lift your staff make them feel
great about themselves in the context of
your business
you do that and i tell you that the
results will astound you
first an idea and then a program
first an idea and then a building
it works every time the newspaper hired
an outside consulting firm to find out
who the review journal who was the best
employer in town
and they did this biggs interviews and
they did a special sunday section
and we won and they and i didn't know
was going on
until mike weaver called me up and told
me and read me what the employees said
ah it was ecstasy this is the greatest
place to work because they listen to you
here
if you've got a good idea they'll
they'll listen to you this is a great
place to work because they're sensitive
to your family problems
they work with when you have those
problems this is the best job i've ever
had in my life
we're the best this is the coolest place
there was this
deep pride at belonging to the team the
family here
in other words it wasn't just the onyx
or the marble or the hand woven carpets
or the
fancy chandeliers and reflected ceiling
plants that are so expensive
it was the living organism that is the
family of staff
and if you get all those things going at
one time listen
last thing i got to say by definition
on this planet from asia to europe
from latin america to canada there has
to be
a best hope place in the world to stay
why can't it be here maybe we're the
best hotel in the world
maybe not for me to say
but you know what from what i understand
from anybody that's ever taken
and reviewed this objectively if we're
not
it we're in the top three now that's a
ki
that's a kicky thing to be able to do up
till 2002
all we focused on was survival and then
once we got public
and and we're profitable we started
thinking wow this thing might last
and the the cruelest irony would be to
not want to work there
um you know to let it become a place we
didn't want to be and so we tried to
think through what do we really care
about and realize what we really care
about is working with incredible people
on hard problems
and that that was the essence so we
should organize everything around
supporting that
of working with you know just incredibly
talented people and so that led us to
freedom and responsibility because
incredible people don't want to be
micromanaged
and the idea is that we manage through
setting context
and letting people run and you've got to
have the right people you've got to
reinforce that with values
setting context about what the company
is trying to achieve
but the idea is to build a system where
amazing amounts of
service improvement happen in the
marketing and the content
and the technology and the user
interface without direct intervention of
meat
and so some companies operate by you
know the product genius at the top
and we all know these companies and this
whole motif of
you know to be a great ceo you've got to
be the great product person who really
you know and it's intoxicating and fun
but you're building incredible amounts
of dependence on yourself
and eventually you know how well i know
how turkish consumers consume netflix
it's not that well and so you're much
stronger obviously building a
distributed
set of great thinkers people know that
but in the past what they've done
is try to make everything a process they
said okay i don't want it to be a genius
so we're going to organize a process for
everything
and these once in a while you heard
we're going to dummy proof it it's going
to be such a good process that anybody
this was the ibm thing
and then if you dummy proof the process
you only get dummies to work there
you know to do the process and so that's
why
we're so you know opposed to that
instead so focused on giving people
great freedom realizing there'll be
mistakes
but there'll be a lot of positive
achievement too can you give some
examples of that
i mean you know you talk about it
generically it sounds great but what are
some specific examples i
i take pride in making as few decisions
as possible
as opposed to as many as possible and so
when something
significant changes in the content or at
the house of cards purchase
you know ted explained it it was a huge
purchase at that time
it was a half an hour conversation you
know we went back and forth i said are
you really sure it's a great bet yes
let's do it
you know it wasn't like me reading the
script and me meeting with kevin spacey
and you know or uh equivalent samples on
the marketing
uh more equivalent examples on um the
product and the evolution there so it's
creating a sense of i want to make a
difference and i can make a difference
and if that's what the leader gets
excited about is that other people are
making a difference and you've got the
right people
you got to be super demanding so the you
know one part is freedom and
responsibility
the other part is a high performance
culture where we say adequate
performance gets a generous severance
package
and so you know we look at it we say we
want to be like a major league baseball
team
and you know you've only got so many
positions on the field and if everyone
is not incredible at what they do
then you're not going to win so you turn
over a lot of people and so we turn over
a lot of people we feel like
you know we give people a fair shot um
and
you know we we hire pretty openly and
they know what they're getting into
but we're looking for people who for
whom freedom and responsibility works
because they do incredible work
one part that i'm always um
very focused on is sort of the structure
of these companies and how
how well are people aligned and so you
can um
and uh making sure that people are you
know aligned properly not just that they
say i think this is sort of a very a
very legal
kind of a framework to think about what
are people's incentives
you know are they going to be lined or
not and i think you want to both have
formal alignment where you set the
structure right and you want to have
informal alignment where the people
would naturally try to work together
well in one
one way or another um and i think that
somehow
tends to get obscured in all these other
ways um you know there's always a
there's always a there's always a
prehistory question i like to ask
founders of of companies which is um
how did you uh how did you
meet what's the pre-history of the
company before you got started
i find that to be really instructive set
of questions to ask
a bad answer is something like you know
we met
a week ago at a social networking
function at a business networking
function we decided to start a company
because we both wanted to be
entrepreneurs
um you know that's like saying i married
the first person i met at the slot
machines in las vegas
and you might hit the jackpot but it's
probably a really bad idea
and a much better answer is you know
we've been talking about this for a long
time
you know maybe one of us is more on the
tech side the other one's more on the
business side we have these sort of
complimentary skills
and uh and so i think this question of
um
alignment and structure is um is
incredibly important
far more is gained by walking on the
shop floor and talking to the people and
trying
to communicate one of my weaknesses has
been i think
i've never communicated enough or
adequately with our people
partly because i'm a shy person
and secondly
because i didn't realize the importance
of communication but i think
communication with the employees
is an exceedingly important function
that
any company chairman has to has to do
and be visible
in that sense i think a good leader has
to be
um a really good listener and um and i'm
listening
uh to fascinating people all the time um
not famous people just you know
you know everybody has some expertise
and sure in something in life
and um and
and i get excited by so many new things
in my environment what happens in our
environment the reason we're growing
is because the code of ethics is
we push we don't want lazy around us we
have a lot of fun okay but when we're
pushing when we're pushing to get the
deal done
and that starts with the leadership you
know here here i am
four days we've been here i haven't been
in the ocean yet
you know i haven't done the little
things that go across the ocean what are
those called uh
uh jet skis the jet skis i haven't
jumped out of the plane even though
everybody
by the way i'd love to skydive and i
probably will come come back in skydive
but i haven't done that because
the region's asking something of me
right and if i'm like i'm too busy i'm
i'm i'm riding camels today great
experience and i will have it
but i have to set priorities in my life
uh the people around me know that i'm
going to take the work
before i'm going to take the the
yeah the leisure yeah uh grant
so pay the price today right yeah the
price and i can pay any price tomorrow
what's your main message on your heart
right now to people in this time
i would keep i would pay people i would
look at the things just like i said
about number one find out
what and who you need to cut same thing
i would tell a household
what and who do you need to cut from
your life
is there some obligation you have that
you don't need going forward
cut it yeah financial is there people in
your life that you could afford to have
in january and you can't afford to have
many more
you got to cut them you got to boss up
right now you got to be
you got to do the tough thing if you
want to take care of your tribe your
group
your family you have to do
leadership is it requires tough
decisions
unpopular decisions the fastest way to
grow a business is to collaborate with
other people
is to find uh these ferries that are
going back and forth b-roll
okay uh the ferries uh dude i mean i
could build a boat
or i could just go right on one of those
exactly right and
what we're doing today is we are
drafting or just collaborating with
yeah um cardone capital
i don't go build apartments no i buy
apartments that are already built
that way i can scale faster if i was
trying to do the building thing now now
construction teams right um
now along the way i'm fixing i'm
adjusting as i go
but but i need to get in the water start
swimming in some direction i think
too many people are trying to figure out
where they're going yeah
and by the time you figure it out
somebody's already there you're trying
to run a business the way you would your
marriage
problem is people gonna quit they're
gonna quit your business easier
because they don't know there's no
culture
and once you have those kids it's hard
to walk out on the marriage
because you can't get rid of the kids
the moment they turn 15 or 18 and they
leave you're like the marriage is over
same thing in a business man the
business falls apart every day you gotta
train your people daily number one think
bigger to get everybody on the same page
educate your people daily three you need
to start following your customers up
hey why didn't you buy the services you
were in you're in here yesterday why
didn't you hook up
why didn't you do it what are you
thinking where are we at you don't have
to make the phone call get get an intern
to make the phone call
i'm on a project right now in a town
i've never been in
where i'm actually that's what i'm doing
i made 11 phone calls for a guy the
other day the
10th phone call guy's like oh yeah i was
thinking about doing that right now it's
a 9 000
sale small town small
think no follow-up i'm not calling new
people by the way
i'm not calling cold people i'm calling
people that are already on this guy's
list
that's not a sales call that's contact
simply contact hey why didn't you buy
the service
why didn't you do it with us why didn't
you
and so that works in any business it
works in law it works in
medical it works and it look like i work
in all these space
financial planning cut it's not the
customer's job to follow you guys up
it's your job to follow them up
and why am i doing that because i don't
want to be dependent upon one or two
customers
i want to get rid of customers and how
do you get rid of customers
scale your business how do you scale a
business
right here don't be satisfied with where
you're at
they're sitting about your sheets at
your house your bed
your house your little comfort your
money your retirement
account it's about can you scale your
big your business big enough that
that's so big that somebody want to buy
your business and that's your exit
they'll get that somebody will get that
i'm not going to get it
april you're going to get that right see
that's the other thing like right now
like like you gotta juggle dude like
you gotta juggle you can't if i get up
now and go answer that phone
it's only because i don't have somebody
here to help me when i roll i gotta have
a team
normally i got two other people with me
i got two kids in the other room
their friend who happens to be here so
we joined up
and their mother's a producer in
hollywood and they happen to be here at
the same time in fact the guy that
andrew banks that's on shark tank in
australia
he was here we had dinner yesterday just
happened running into each other but you
got to have a team
nobody was telling me when i started a
business bro you need a team
you're going to need a team man you want
to be super freaking super
successful spider-man pro spider-man
doesn't have a team
does he i think he does his own costume
but it's stupid
like how can you be spider-man and do
your own costume
right i mean to be superman i mean
batman's got a team
right superman he's got a team doesn't
he have a team
i don't think he does maybe he's got a
mama but that's for the comic books man
you need a team
well that's an interesting thing right
because i i
i've like studied you and i've seen like
you know you've got alan
you've got um yeah i got alan on my team
yeah you've got
um a-l-a-n on instagram you've got the
young guy
the president yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i'm
curious i got ron sucko ron sacco yeah
he was a pilot now he's
now he's uh running a 1.2 billion dollar
real estate portfolio i've got sherry
hamilton
i got personal assistance i got 150 we
got 150
employees in miami another 250 in the
real estate
that could be 500 easily in the real
estate
you know there's probably 500 employees
between the two businesses right now
and i'm sitting here thinking why don't
i have 50 000 employees
okay i look out i look out here in these
windows central equity okay i guarantee
you that that's not a one-man show right
there
you don't get your name on the building
being one person i think
accountability is underrated i think the
easiest person to lie to is yourself
yeah whether it's competition or team or
husband or wife or partner yeah or
the need for success and it's not always
the family members that can do it like
like sometimes i need to hear from
somebody other than the person i sleep
with
or my mommy and daddy you know because
mommy and daddy are just gonna be like i
love you just the way you are
yeah but when you start getting input
from somebody outside your bloodline
you know i remember a guy about four or
five years ago he was
he just sold his company he was worth
4.4 billion dollars at the time he just
had a big score
but he had a lifetime of doing deals
you know and this one thing finally hit
and
his impression of me was completely
different
than what anybody else says to me and
what he told me was
hey grant you can do more like and when
he said that it was just like
wow from him you can do more grant
grant you should do more grant you must
do more
and i was like wow it just like it just
like it was riveting
and and at that time i was looking at
buying the jet he's like you absolutely
should buy a jet
you should and he's not a wasteful guy
this is a fairly frugal guy
he didn't waste money he didn't show off
he's never on social media
and he says look you you have the gift
to help a lot of people man
you're extremely transparent person you
tell people like it is
you want to you want to help people
and he's like you need to go travel the
world and make sure you help people
and so that was an inspiration from a
guy that's done a lot yeah
as opposed to my family saying like if
it's a family member this is what i'm
going to hear most of time
man don't you think you're working too
hard huh don't you think you're doing
too much when's enough enough
when are you just going to be happy are
you spending enough time with the kids
you enjoying life this little little
things they drop
i can i know you hear this when are you
just going to be
satisfied with rob you know yeah
but this guy looking in said dude you
can do more yeah and then people need
that outside
in inspiration and accountability now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
my definition of leadership is wanting
the people on your team
to win more than you want them to win
with you
i want the people on my team to win as
humans
more than i want them to win with me
that's good karma
that keeps you positive and happy but it
also wins your team's heart and souls
and not just their brains so i like to
think of relationships as parallel paths
whenever i'm interacting with somebody
it's a parallel path even you and i
right now this is a parallel path that
we are on
right now for the next however many
minutes and then i'm off doing my thing
and you're gonna go off and do your
thing
and maybe we come back on the same
parallel path and we meet again or maybe
this is the last time i see you
sorry to see you go but hopefully you're
off doing your life
crushing it and and we've moved on and i
think that's normal and you'll have
people come into your life and you run
together
and sometimes the best thing in life is
for them to stay with you as a running
mate
for for a day for a week for life for a
decade
and sometimes the best thing for them is
to actually move away
and now running with you is no longer
the best thing for them
and that's your job now to push them
away and go do it maybe they come back
at some point in the future
if you're lying again i think about a
friend of mine named bo hawkins and beau
has been a friend for a number of years
he's super active on my youtube channel
and a while ago two years ago we started
a new show called the bow show
and the bow show was him going to be
interviewing different people and
bringing them to my youtube channel
he loves reaching out he's got a knack
for being able to find
and get access to exclusive people and
he wanted to run an interview show but
his channel was a little bit small
and so he said can i use your channel i
thought yes the very first interview he
did was with
uh wim hof and i wanted to get to wim
hof and he wanted to get the garyvee and
garyvee had been on my channel so i
introduced him to gary and he did an
interview with him he introduced me to
whim
and i did a whole session with wim and
went and did the ice packs with nina and
had a bunch of fun
and so we launched the bose show and at
that point then beau became
very heavily involved in what we're
doing he's he's reaching out we're
pointing his shows we're in contact
a lot back and forth then he came to my
thought leadership academy
in toronto and was one of the helpers
and was coaching people how to get these
introductions how do you
get access to big names and then he got
a big client
and he shut down his youtube channel and
didn't post any content and wasn't doing
interviews
and he kind of left the parallel paths
right it's like awesome i'm so pumped
for you go do your thing he's doing
netflix specials he's
he's making tons of money he's doing
dream projects that he's working on and
he kind of left
to go do his thing and then he messaged
me about a month ago
uh this was like two years ago he was
doing the bow show nothing messaged me
about a month ago and said hey
evan i want to launch the bose show
again i'm like yeah baby
let's go right and so he he got gary v
back on he got whim hop back on he's got
some exciting other guests lined up
that we're going to bring back to the
main channel and he
was on parallel path and he left and
like you know to stay in touch every now
and then
and now he's back right now again maybe
this parallel path of bow
is a lifetime maybe maybe i talk to bo
every day for the rest of my life until
one of us dies or we we die together
holding hands you know i don't know who
knows what will happen
or maybe this is another stretch for
three months and then and then he finds
another passion props and goes and does
that
you don't know but the door is still
open
it was at a great run two years ago and
now we're setting off on another run and
hopefully that lasts for a long time
but if the best thing for him ultimately
is to go off and do something else
that's great
and my door's always open to come back
and jump on this pillow path and so
that's how i try to approach
relationships is that you come together
and again for us we're spending this
little bit of time together
and maybe the best thing for us is to
keep going and maybe the best thing for
you is to watch a morning video every
single day
if that's your path i'm honored i'm
grateful it's great to be here together
i hope i can inspire you with the
the shot of entspresso every morning
it's amazing
and maybe we end up doing something even
more closer together maybe you've got
the next killer app that i'm going to
invest in and help blow up and maybe we
become
business partners in a bunch of
different ventures i've done that with
10 or so different people from my
audience we've
launched different ventures together and
my goal always
is to have the person i'm running with
grow as a human
to get better i want people to feel like
they have gotten better as a result of
spending time with me it's important to
me i want you
to learn even in this video i want you
to learn
more and grow more than i want your view
or your subscription
on my channel if you took this video and
then ran with it
and then blew up your life not just
business your life
i never came back and watched another
video of mine i'm pumped
some people say hey evan you introduced
me to jocko willink
and i was watching all your videos and
now i don't watch as much because i go
watch
jocko sorry man i'm pumped right if i'm
no longer the best person for you
amazing go off and do that thing because
it always comes back like people are
afraid of the loss you're afraid of
losing that person you're afraid of
losing that connection
it always comes back like bo right
whether they actually come back and join
your team again or they're just off in
the world saying good things about you
good karma always comes back
and it makes you happier it makes you
positive it makes you stop living in
fear
in potential regret mode and this person
is going to leave
in scarcity mindset and whenever you're
making decisions from that mindset
you're never gonna win
so think about the people on your team
and want them to win as humans more than
you want them to win with you
now i've got a three-step process for
how to do it that i'm going to teach you
right now
step number one is try to wear their
skin one of the greatest tools i think
you can ever develop as a human is to
learn how to wear somebody else's skin
that's my own kind of weird term for it
i think people usually say
walk a mile in somebody's shoes wear
their shoes i want to wear their skin i
want to be that person
i'm trying to be that person when i'm
talking to them and try to think about
not what i want them to do when how evan
carmichael is where a lot of people fall
down you tell people
what you would do in their situation
when people come and ask for advice you
say well i would do this
that's terrible advice what you would do
doesn't matter
what should they do and the best advice
you can give them is to actually try to
be them
understand their hopes their desires
their their dreams their core values
what they care about the most
not from you being the entrepreneur but
from them being in the position that
they're in right now
what's the best thing for them and so
try to put yourself in the practice
of wearing their skin of trying to be
them right if they're in front of you
or you can see them on a zoom call try
to sit like them try to
try to cross your arms like them try to
have their posture right somebody who's
like this is thinking differently than
somebody who's like this
try to put yourself in their headspace
wear their skin to get as close to
understanding
what they're thinking what they're going
through to give them the best advice for
what they should do next
wear their skin number two is have
regular non-operational check-ins
what i try to do is everybody on my team
i'm meeting with uh at least once a
quarter
and i'm trying to check in with them to
see how they're doing not just
of what needs to get done and think this
is a trap that sometimes i fall into i
think a lot of entrepreneurs
easily fall into when you're connecting
with somebody on your team it's about
did you get this done and brainstorming
new ideas and it's just work work work
business business business
as opposed to just asking about the
person
how are you doing do you like what
you're doing
how's life do you want to be doing more
do you want to be doing less how can i
be a part of what you're trying to
accomplish in your role or just
in life for my team who are around the
world before i hop on a call with them
i'll always go to google news and see
what's happening in their country
maybe there was some earthquake maybe
there was some election maybe there's
some big storm or some news
that they might not share up front in a
call because they they're living it but
they may not think it's relevant
but the fact that i know that that's
happening in their country is
interesting or even in their state or
their city i do this for clients too
when i'm talking to somebody i was
talking to somebody else who's got a
youtube channel based out of vegas
and uh i look up what's happening in las
vegas so that i'm
just headline news what's happening in
las vegas right now it's just a good
practice to get into to
understand the mindset of what that
person's going through right now
so i look at somebody like ray who's on
my team who's in charge of all my
thumbnails
and we're doing split testing and
thumbnails across all my channels and
we're doing
another 3 000 thumbnail experiments this
year it's crazy
and so we talk once a month to plan out
our thumbnails and we talk
every day through messenger or hangouts
but once a month will be a big strategy
session and then once a quarter i'm
still sitting down with him to talk
about just how is he doing
how's his life how's his relationship
what is he liking about
working with me what does he want to
tweak or change or fix or improve
what ideas does he have to want to make
things better just a regular
non-operational check-in
can go a long way to actually learning
how to wear somebody's skin
and get inside their head again not so
that you can manipulate them
but so you can influence them and help
them and lead them to have a best life
for themselves
and then step number three is look to
help them progress so you're wearing
their skin
you've learned about their city you're
doing regular you know non-operational
check-ins and you've learned about them
and what they care about
now how can you help sometimes it may
mean you have to educate yourself
so for example there was a person on my
team who had lyme disease i'd never
heard of what lyme disease was
never knew what it was never heard about
it didn't care i'm ignorant about most
things
but the fact that he had it now i went
to google news and i created a news
alert around lando seens
and when something came out about lyme
disease that was interesting new novel
some new study or some new celebrity
came out shania twain has it avril
lavigne has it justin bieber has it
i would share it with that person and it
made made them feel
like i cared and i did care right i'm
not everyday going
lyme disease lyme disease lyme disease
right but the fact that it
was in my news alerts and i was thinking
about that person made them feel special
so it has nothing to do with my business
right i'm always looking for
opportunities to help somebody grow and
learn what skills that you want to pick
up
but outside of that what do they care
about what are they struggling with and
how can you be a potential resource
and the more it's even outside of what
you're supposed to do as a boss
the better it is even for that
relationship so look for ways to help
them progress
look for people who step up it's not
about their resume
it's not about where they used to work
it's not about how good their references
are
it's about are they willing to do the
work when other people aren't
and it's up to you to give them the
opportunity to step
up and shine and so i think about one of
the businesses that i run toronto dance
salsa largest salsa dance school maybe
north america
and when i first took it over the
original owner had to leave the business
because her back was hurting
and she couldn't dance anymore it was
causing her
severe physical harm and there was one
guy named alex
who now helps run the business who was
her assistant who was training with her
and i knew alex and i didn't think alex
you know would do a good job as an
instructor i was actually against him
even training to be an instructor
because he wasn't committed he wasn't
following through he wasn't taking
feedback most importantly
and here he was training with her
and when she came down with the injury i
was the only person who could actually
go and teach
that class as at least a short-term gap
and so
alex became super deflated because
a guy can't dance with another guy i
mean i guess you could but in our motto
it's usually
a man and woman at the front so if i'm
coming in to teach the class
then i would have a female assistant
and so alice is really bummed one
because the origin owner is injured and
now two the thing he worked so hard for
was being taken away from him
so he comes to pick me up from my place
we're driving over to toronto dance elsa
and i say hey i've got we got two
two choices here one
i'll teach and you can watch i'll still
train you
because she was training you and i'll
honor that commitment and you need to
show up for your training and make sure
you're doing your part
so i could teach the class and you could
sit on the sidelines
and i'll train you or two you take over
the class
now it's your class and we'll give you a
female assistant
and i'll train you from the sidelines
one do you want and he didn't know the
material there's so many reasons why i
wouldn't work out he's got three hours
of teaching he had to do that night that
he wasn't prepared to do
the entire class for and he was already
going in expecting that
he was gonna be benched and he said i'll
do it
and it's in these moments that this is
when i recognize
great people from my team like when
you're not ready
but you're given an opportunity do you
step up he wouldn't have been given that
opportunity by most people
he wasn't ready he made tons of mistakes
he had to teach the man
and the women's part and he barely knew
the women's part
and i'm not so concerned about did he
get it perfect what i'm concerned about
is did he try
is he saying yes and i love throwing
people into opportunities
and seeing if they have that in them to
say
i'll do it i'll do my best i'll try
those are the people you want to
surround yourself with now fast forward
to where we are now
it's something i have to remind alex of
when he's training new people
he's bringing new people on and now he's
built himself up to having such a high
standard for what a class looks like
that he doesn't let people move on until
they've
hit almost mastery so you need to lower
the bar
you need to give people opportunities
you need to give them a taste you need
to see what they're made of see if
they're capable
do you remember how bad you were when
you first started
i have to remind him about the process
about how
there was one move that he didn't want
to teach at all didn't feel comfortable
was word that he would fall and fall
down on his face while while doing it
turning twice and he said can you teach
this evan like nope you're teaching it
if you fall you fall and he went up and
he taught it and he didn't fall
and so reminding him now that he needs
to treat
the people on his team who are under him
now that he's bees built up
and give them opportunities and not hold
them back because they're not perfect
you want to find the people who are
willing to step up but you can't just
blame them
are you giving people the opportunities
are you allowing them
to shine are you giving them some rope
to play with and not hanging them
if they make a mistake so yes it's about
finding people but it's two
also about you owning your role to say
are you giving your team the opportunity
to step
up and impress not just you but impress
themselves as well
okay how do we do it how do we build a
better team how do we build a better
culture how do we get people to step
up three steps let's go step number one
is fixing your hiring process most
people have a broken hiring process
most people hire people based off of
the resume the cover letter an interview
and references that's typically
the process right most of those things
don't test for what they're actually
going to be doing
you're putting people through this
machine that is totally unrelated to the
work they're actually going to be doing
if you're trying to hire a videographer
for example
you're trying to hire an editor for
example for a youtube channel
what their resume looks like doesn't
matter what their cover looks like
doesn't matter like their ability to
write
a cover letter doesn't matter you're
hiring an editor i don't care how
how well you write if you're shakespeare
in writing but you suck at editing
it doesn't matter references are almost
always bs
and interviews as well almost always
don't work
because again somebody could be the most
introverted shy
person of all time and suck in an
interview
but be great as an editor so most of the
time i think the hiring process is
broken and people are
are not judging people correctly the
best way to do it
i think is to actually work on projects
together so what we'll do is when i'm
doing a job post
it'll actually be one big ugly paragraph
and somewhere in the middle
we'll ask some kind of skill testing
question like tell me how many youtube
subscribers i have
and put that in the first line of your
application eighty percent of the people
who apply for a job
don't even catch that question never
find my youtube channel and don't put it
in the first line of
their application so if you're not gonna
spend time actually reading
my job ad why am i going to spend time
reading your application this is why
it's broken
it takes them eight seconds to click
apply
and they're just using the same cover
letter resume everything they've done
for everybody else
but it takes you it takes you time to
read every one of them part of why
we hate the hiring process because it
takes so long that then if you finally
get somebody through this broken process
you don't want to lose them and you keep
somebody who's just
okay because you want to go through that
painful process all over again
if they don't respond to the skill
testing question right away
you already lose 80 of the people now
you've got 20 to work with and what i
love doing next
is having a trial job so instead of
interviewing or anything else
we're going to work on a project
together i'll give up the five hours on
a project
go edit this video let's see what you
got and in the process of working with
them
it actually maps really well to the work
they're going to be doing if they
actually got the job
and we see how well do they work
together how quickly are they working do
they ask smart questions
are they delivering a quality product
and in that in that paid
trial it's a paid trial in a patreon we
figure out who we end up wanting to work
with and it's often
it's often the people who don't look
great on paper a lot of the people on my
team
don't look that great on paper but
they're great
they're great people and so fix your
hiring process and in your selection
process
you're testing for the things that you
actually care about that map well
to the job that they're gonna have
because most people's hiring process
is dead broken step number two is give
them opportunities
so when you have people it's like great
what else are you working on building
growing learning what do they want to
get into one of the advantages of being
an entrepreneur is
there's so many things so many ideas we
have so many places we want to grow so
many
new things we want to do chances are
somebody's not going to come into
a job and just do the same thing you
know just stamping this one thing
all day long like they would in the
manufacturing company there's
opportunities but it's on you to
actually give them opportunities
it's on you to have a conversation with
them and believe in them
and see that kind of hidden talent
inside of them to say hey i think you
could be great at this
do you want to give it a shot yes they
have to step up and own their role but a
lot of times
they don't because you as the
entrepreneur haven't given them
that opportunity if you're not giving
opportunities and you
you expect your team to say hey what
what else can i do
where can i step up i'd love to be of
greater service
you can't just put all the
responsibility on them that makes it
really difficult
some people will do that and that's a
that's an insane superstar for your team
but you need to do your role as a leader
to see more
in the person than they see in
themselves and give them that chance to
rise up and shine
and then set number three is expect
imperfection don't expect the first
thing that they do to be great
it's more did they step up do you see
potential is there something there that
you can work with
when i gave alex that opportunity to go
and teach the class instead of sitting
on the sidelines he made tons of
mistakes he was super nervous
it wasn't great he made mistakes
everywhere it wasn't
to the point where we were letting our
students down and it was a
disappointment
and they were asking for refunds or
anything but compared to
how the the founder would have taught it
compared to how i would have taught it
it wasn't hitting the level but i gave
him feedback
on the breaks and i gave him feedback
after the class and i gave him feedback
for the next weeks as i kept coming back
to the class and mentoring him and he
got better
so i expect imperfections expect it not
to be perfect
don't focus on all the reasons why it
sucked and try to give some
encouragement and say hey
these things are really great let's
continue to improve here and here's how
you can get better
expect imperfection if they see your
face like
if i'm on the sidelines doing this as
alex is teaching it's over he's lost
he's lost his confidence he's not going
to do it anymore and it's not even just
not expressing it it's not feeling it
i expect it if he fell on his face for
that move that he wanted me to go off
and teach it would be okay
everything is savable i expect
imperfections
and if you're throwing people into new
opportunities you should too
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have and i think a lot of businesses
fail because the entrepreneur cannot
communicate well and if
they even are sharing their ideas they
are not
convincing enough and so a lot of great
ideas die
you could have the next greatest idea
that can change the world it's sitting
up here
but because you can't articulate it
because you can't share it because you
can't communicate it well and because
you're not convincing enough
to the people around you it will never
take off the idea will die within you
and i hate that
i hate that because building a business
getting the thing that's out here out
into the world is greater than one
person
no matter how much of a genius you are
to build a business you need a team
you need a team of people to help you go
far and you also need to convince
the media and customers and partners and
suppliers that what you have
is amazing if you are the only one who
thinks that your idea
is amazing and you can't communicate or
convince anybody else of that
then you're done then that idea dies
within you and i think unfortunately
that's a lot of entrepreneurs so jordan
has three of his tips i'm gonna give you
three of mine on how to be a convincing
communicator
step number one is have a powerful
opinion you have an opinion
what is it that you are trying to say
make it mean something to yourself
and into me and make that the first
sentence of
every piece of content that you make if
you're doing a video that's your first
sentence you do an instagram post
put it in there you're doing a linkedin
post an email a newsletter like
put it in there you lead with your
powerful opinion
on what is wrong with the world or what
your viewpoint on
xyz topic is make it mean something to
me
make me care so if i'm talking about
communication how important it is for
entrepreneurs
a powerful opinion would be something
like you need to learn
how to communicate in your business or
you will never get that idea that's in
your head out into the world and your
idea will die
inside you that's an opinion where lots
of people might say something like
so if you want to learn how to build a
successful business
and maybe take your idea to the next
level
i think maybe you should focus on trying
to
improve how you speak and communicate
like
it's so long it has lots of filler words
you use words like
maybe and potentially and someday and
one day and i wish and
we instead of i like affirmative
stop worrying about what people's
reactions are going to be and speak your
truth
always lead with a powerful opinion tip
number two is emotional commitment
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
really fall down you've got your
powerful opinion you know what you stand
for you know what you're trying to
communicate
but when you get in front of a camera or
when you get down to writing
it doesn't sway people it's not
emotional enough you could be saying
all the best words when you get in front
of a camera to make a video
but because you are talking in a very
boring very non-exciting manner and
because
you're so worried about saying the
perfect words
that you are memorizing something or you
are
looking at your script or trying to read
from a teleprompter
nobody is going to care or listen to you
you need to have emotional commitment
you need to feel the
thing and how important it is while you
are saying it for me
i'm envisioning all of you i'm
envisioning all the entrepreneurs that
i've worked with who have
these amazing ideas and they never get
them out because they can't communicate
and even though i'm sitting here in an
office by myself and there's nobody
around to actually connect with
i'm just talking to a camera i'm trying
to channel you i'm trying to channel all
the people that i've connected with
and seen and i want to make sure that
your business
does well and communicating is so
important as part of that which is why
i'm doing this video and hopefully the
care the love the energy comes through
in the content that i make and so sales
and convincing people
not enough against what they want but in
a positive way like this is something
that you guys can get together on
is about the energy transfer you are not
just selling a concept or an idea you
are transferring energy
whoever is more confident wins whoever
is more convincing wins and it's usually
from
whoever believes in their thing more if
you absolutely believe in your thing and
that this is right and it's for them and
they need to do this thing
because it's in their best interest not
because they're just trying to sell
something
down their throat but you really really
really really care
and if they feel that care as opposed to
just
words that you're saying that's how you
bring them on board
it's great to have the best words but
more important
is the emotional commitment that you
have behind them so the best test with
any of this is watch back
some of your content like watch back
your videos read your newsletters
see the copy on your website look at the
story that you wrote about yourself and
why you started this business
does it get you excited it's like boom
boom boom boom like yes
that's right that's why i do this thing
or do you watch it and you get bored
if you get bored and it doesn't get your
heart beating then do it again
do it again and do it again and do it
again and do it again
you will be one of your best critics you
will be one of your harshest critics
and so being able to look over your
content and get to the point where you
say
wow yeah i'm really proud of that
that's when you start to win and tip
number three is raise mistakes
just make it more important if you want
to move people
so often we're focused just on the
tactics the strategies
here's the five things that you need to
do and people say yeah yeah yeah great i
love those the five things
awesome they write them down and then
they never do anything about it
you need to raise the stakes you have to
make it more important you have to make
me
feel the pressure that if i don't do
this thing that you want me to do
terrible things will happen
right so if i talk about how important
communication is
me just saying communication is really
important as an entrepreneur
here are the three ways to do it it's
not as powerful as
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have because if you
don't learn how to communicate your idea
and get it out there
that idea will die inside you and your
mission will never be realized
and listen that paints a dark picture
that's going to an extreme and the idea
is
not to have hyperbole and make things
bigger than they are
but that's a real case for tons of
entrepreneurs
that if they do not learn how to
communicate properly their ideas will
never get out there and their idea will
die inside them and so your goal if you
want to move people
is to make them realize how big this
thing is for them
if they don't take action you're the
expert you know where the road is going
you see
their future if they continue down that
path they don't see that future
they don't understand it it's your job
to help them see
where this current path of action is
going to lead them
and if they make the tweak they make the
change they take your recommendations
where it could go raise the stakes make
it more important
make them feel that it's more important
and it actually starts with you
feeling that this message is insanely
important if you want to sign up for the
entire billionaire mindset series for
free and get the companion bonus pdf
calendar check the link
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there